michel c'est au jai alai castonguay
bonsoir
je vous ai vu j'avais entendu sourire
michel c'est qu'on a paris je vois le
guette
vous avez suivi dans cette histoire là
avec beaucoup de passion puis c'est
resté dans les annales politiques bien
sûr ça a marqué l'histoire américaine ça
a marqué l'histoire des mensonges en
politique jeudi avant la pause chez que
je devais pas vous parler ça mais j'y
vais comme j'étais dans la rue c'est
quand même incroyable on fête les 50 ans
on sait mais on souligne les 50 ans de
régime alors que on est en plein
mensonge tram énorme actuellement et lui
dans ce même se représenter à la
présidence tchèque jugée comme si on
avait pu les mêmes codes
or c'est clair qu'on n'a plus les mêmes
coin de l'âtre andy est devenu tellement
lâche aux dominantes de la politique
américaine que la vérité parce qu'en
deuxième fait ça c'est évident
cela dit est ce que trump a su
représenter
résultats
continuaient d'être certain mais ce qui
plaît aussi c'est que avec ce que lui
république et avait dans les mains dans
le dos et ils étaient prêts est de
constituer aujourd'hui même après le 6
janvier des républicains se sont tenues
avec toi bien juste dix qui ont voté
contre lui
c'est la preuve de la polarisation et de
la partie a links était stable vous
suivez ça aussi alex bien sûr cette
commission aux états unis du 7 janvier
et comment on s'aperçoit avec plusieurs
entrevues de ses proches comment ils
essayaient de se trouver une voie dans
le mensonge dans le déni redit à moi la
parole du peuple la constitution je me
souhaite côté puis je vais dire que j'ai
gagné jusqu'à temps que peut-être assez
de gens me croient et le problème c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui l'ont cru
alec
mais en 72 avec nixon comme c'est le cas
maintenant c'est que c'est la fin
justifie les moyens tous les moyens sont
bons pour gagner à l'époque donné le
parti démocrate maintenant s'il
prétendre que l'élection ait volé mais
on est dans le même objectif ou la
partie emery est plus importante que les
institutions ou et à l'époque par contre
chez les raisons il y avait plus de
garde-fous parti républicain il y avait
plus de joueurs pour qui le respect de
l'institution la maison blanche et est
importante on avait brisé le code et on
était prêt à mettre son propre président
d'or pour préserver ce qui fait des
etats unis une démocratie le c'est pas
mal moins clag partie des publics et
encore audiard en deux sets de ce
respect des institutions là et c'est ça
qui est troublant c'est qu'il ya plus
beaucoup de garde-fous à l'intérieur
d'un grand parti pourtant le parti
républicain pour empêcher un président
qui veut prendre tous les moyens pour
rester au pouvoir de le faire c'est
vraiment très troublant vous avez raison
d'un bon mot vraiment l'ont dit hier je
reviens sur notre cheval
notre premier sujet brûlant journée
que dis je me reconnais pas je vais vous
faire lire les extraits ne le pense on
l'a fait à la question est ce que vous
vous reconnaissez dans le parti
conservateur monsieur journée
aujourd'hui d'aller voir le la diapo
tellement écrit-il dit il je mentionnais
certaines des réalisations ce ne sera
pas pour ce ne serait pas possible ce
parti là mais il ya du beau monde qui
veulent des changements plat la question
sur jean charest dit je sais que mon ami
jean charest va très bien il ya de très
bons candidats et c'est loin d'être
gagné par pour qui que ce soit donc
refuse de voir poilievre gagnant absolue
mais disent une façon bizarre de se
choisir un chef le premier choix
deuxième choix de troisième joueur tout
en même temps il dit les bonnes vieilles
convention ou sont elles alors
je vous fait attendre tout de suite oui
mais si
vous ramenez demande
pierre paul-hus et gérard deltell qui
réagissent à ça
premièrement le parti conservateur de
musée malraux ni de l'hépatite parti
progressiste conservateur c'était un
autre parti peut-être une autre
philosophie parce qu'on sera attendu
qu'elle adore c'est parti conservateur
du cadeau que je connais moi depuis que
je t'ai pic à 2008 puis ses célèbres
l'opinion
pour
le parti tel qu'il est chaque chef
imprime son approche comme monsieur
mulroney l'a fait et comme d'autres
l'ont fait comme ça après le fait alors
avec des styles complètement différents
et ça c'est normal ces révolutions d'un
parti politique
la question qui décolle de ça c est ce
que c'est pierre poilievre problème
l'emportent le parti pourra vraiment se
ressouder et le chef louis va imprimer
une direction mais en a peut-être qui
vont rester derrière michel
il faut pas oublier que le parti de
monsieur varone il participe aux
grossistes conservateur quand tu la
fusion avec l'alliance canadienne
c'était très clairement le partenaire
junior de l'infusion on a plus acheter
le nom conservateur qui est une des
barrières banque de commerce qu'on a
fait bien place aux idées des
progressistes conservateurs qui est des
petits partis les deux alors c'est vrai
que c'est plus son parti c'est une autre
époque et c'était parti qui dans le
centre de gravité s'est déplacé vers
l'ouest est aussi maladroite plus à
droite que l'album le second nommé qui
est un homme du chantre et c'est
aujourd'hui
oui
alec et c'est poilievre comme prévu je
vous donnais je vais vous donner après
des chutes comme prévu l'emportent
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sur car même
l'unité de ce parti là bas
il va y avoir des gros questionnement
chez bien des militants chez même
peut-être des députés qui se disait
qu'il y avait encore plus de la dn
progressiste conservatrice
parce que pour la première fois
clairement d'une course à la direction
avec un des joueurs sérieux comme
patrick brown comme jean charest s'est
affolé le rapport ça voudra dire que ce
courant là n'est plus suffisant pour
faire valoir ses idées à la terre du
parti si lyon n'a pas l'impression puis
à polir leur fait une place dans le
parti ont l'impression qu'ils passent
plus de temps à courtiser les partisans
de maxime bernier du parti populaire du
canada qui ont quitté le parti pour
former leurs franges très à droite qui
font pourtant à 3 4 5 % dans les
sondages que d'aller chercher des idées
du parti progressiste conservateur
d'aller chiper des idées qui pourraient
plaire à des partisans de jean charest
ou patrick brown ou du côté de chez sun
que dans la courtoisie comme on l'entend
pas beaucoup la main et donc ça veut
est-ce qu'ils vont sentir bienvenu après
c'est ses partisans lors de jean charest
de patrick brand une très bonne question
parce qu'ils vont vouloir former un
autre parti divisé la droite ce qu'ils
vont rester à la maison lors des
élections vont-ils aller voter chez les
libéraux qui sous un autre chef qui sera
peut-être un peu moins à gauche il va y
avoir des questionnements des militants
conservateurs qui pourraient se sentir
orphelin à la suite d'une victoire de
poids avant qu'on analyse plus avant les
chiffres que pensez vous bon ben on va
les analyser là on voit poilievre 40 cas
le bleu la ligne bleue c'est les
conservateurs la ligne rouge pas les
libéraux c'est dense et tous les gens
sondés l'ensemble alors poilievre est
très populaire chez les militants
conservateurs et dans l'ensemble la
population il est beaucoup moins jean
charest stable et le même score et chez
l'ensemble de la population et chez les
conservateurs 14 et bras en est à 6 4
avec des chiffres comme cela
est-ce que c'est réglé messieurs pour
pierre poilievre michel c
c'est pas réglé mais c'est bien proche
d'être réglé le problème actuellement
c'est la dengue lutte contre le rouge et
or à misery à une élection générale il
faut devenir sa femme en
même temps des bruits qu'on entend sur
le nombre de membres qu'il a réussi à
signer par rapport aux deux autres il
est vraiment très en avance évidemment
il peut faire d'un milliard d'ici le
mois de septembre aérienne de
complètement joué mais monsieur poignet
il ya une espèce de moments poilievre le
parti conservateur ont deux sets droite
dure là plutôt que des progressistes
conservateurs comme comme ceux comme
monsieur charest
rigueur donc c'est vraiment ça va
vraiment être très difficile faut boire
falloir enfin qu'elle produit m la perte
de lui grosse gaffe qui va lui faire
perdre l'élection mais ça semble pas
s'en aller je vous d'accord avec eux
c'est pas mal
aubriot kibera qui disait que c'est pas
fini tant que ce n'est pas fini la met
dedans que d'une avance comme celle là
je te suis d'accord que ça va être
difficile à surmonter il ya toujours un
système de pointage un peu complexe doit
parti conservateur qui fait qu'il faut
qu'on qu'on attende un peu pour voir où
sont réparties ces appuis la très
populaire en alberta au manitoba
saskatchewan ça nous permet pas de
l'emporter au parti conservateur mais
reste que son avance elle est quand même
très forte s'ils l'emportent jobs devant
un peu commun avec l'est du canada avec
le québec un chef pierre poilievre
réussir à se réconcilier car dès
aujourd'hui sa dernière promesse le
souhait de mettre à la poubelle la loi
c-11 qui va être votée dans les
prochains jours à la chambre des
communes c'est honteux c'est obligé les
géants du web léa pommette flic sa
maison de contribuer à l'écosystème
culturel car a dit un peu comme les
câblodistributeurs le forme si
théoriquement donc mettre l'argent dans
la cagnotte là pour qu'on puisse avoir
disserté l'épididyme des musiciens ici
ludysol off c'est fini on met de côté
est une demande unanime de l'assemblée
nationale de l'industrie culturelle qui
en mène large au québec lui faudra
qu'explique la à sa droite est-ce que je
prend un virage pour aller chercher des
sièges au québec où je passe toute une
campagne électorale sur la défensive sur
cette question là sans parler des autres
questions dont il parle il écrit thomas
donné un fils la banque du canada donc
le candidat pierre poilievre même élu ou
sept partis conservateurs vous ça va
être intéressant de voir s'il est
capable de les compétitifs lors de
l'élection générale
ça c'est le 10 septembre en passant
mesdames et messieurs le le choix chez
les conservateurs ils vont voter avant
ce qu'ils vont faire leurs premiers
choix leur deuxième choix leur troisième
choix leur quatrième choix et cetera en
même temps donc c'est pas une convention
comme on disait un congrès pardon ou la
dynamique fait car on change d'idée on
va vers un tout ça va être réglé avant
michels et je reviens et alec je reviens
sur cette théorie il en fait des gens
qui disent y poilievre gangs comme c'est
ça semble être le cas il ya une scission
il y aura des gens qui ont envie de
créer un nouveau parti conservateur plus
au centre et c'est peut-être là l'écueil
pour monsieur poilley parce que même si
ce parti là ne voit pas si loin il peut
brouiller les cartes lors d'un prochain
scrutin michel c'est
quoi écrire partie ces deux ouvrages ont
commencé à dire on va on va faire ça
rapidement depuis l'élection sans vie et
les conservateurs se disent beaucoup
aussi on est à la fin de ces des
libéraux auraient tout pouvoir pendant
une dizaine d'années de toute façon
l'alternance va jouer pour nous même si
il ne trouve pas si l'ex emploi lièvre
ils vont dire c'est le tas de changer de
gouvernement bull on en tableaux chez
les partisans de monsieur croyait la fin
du cycle alors
il y avait peut-être déjà qui décideront
de rester à la maison les députés du
québec en particulier en essayant de ne
pas se représenter ça c'est très
possible mais dire qu'on en parle former
un parti politique chaud c'est pas
évident et ça prend plus de mam et
maxime bernier
d'accord alex est plus une presque une
vue de l'esprit qu une carte routière
concrètes
le travail de terrain le travail de
structures de partis qui effectivement
prend du temps à créer mais ça prendrait
un chef
qui quittera ensemble pour si peu de
temps capable d'avoir un succès
électoral donc à ce que jean charest a
le goût lui il faut battu mettons le
supérieur ce que le goodwill de se
lancer dans la création d'un parti avec
toute l'énergie que sa demande j'ai déjà
été chef de partie où il y avait pas de
député ou président de la chambre des
communes est ce que le goût de revivre
ça
le goût donc de faire une tournée du
pays d'être il serait très bon parce
qu'il ya encore de 7,7 fait brûlant
l'huile on le voit de ce feu sacré mais
ça prendra un nom comme ça là patrick
grande malheureusement je pense aux
français pas suffisamment bons pour
prétendre avoir un chef de parti
pancanadien mais il ça prendrait un gros
nom pour être capable de mettre sur les
rails puiseront yves appuyons advienne
que pourra si ces projets charest je
vois pas la possibilité de créer ce
parti de la côte parce que pour lièvre
doit gagner le thé l'ontario c'est sûr
qu'ils brown a déjà dit moi je quitte
s'il devient chef je m'en avait le jeu
serait papa je serai pas candidat je
serais rien du tout ce choix aurait ne
sera pas une évidence candidats sous
enchère poilievre donc il ya des gens
qui vont partir avec eux inévitablement
michel
oui les gens qui vont partir il ya des
gens qui mais ils partiront pas
nécessairement ailleurs ils vont passer
pour la maison
c'est parti à la maison
on verra ce que ce que ça donne et on
verra si ça fait jouer le principe de
l'alternance ou si les libéraux dans
cette situation alors peut-être avec un
nouveau chef un peu plus à droite comme
sur trudeau serait pas capable de se
maintenir mais là on est vraiment la
conjecture
ouais on va attendre et j'allais
demander à l'est quand en conclusion
qu'est ce qu'on surveille d'ici le 10
septembre parce que là les gens
à partir de quel moment ils commencent à
voter puisque qu'est ce qui pourrait
arriver qui pourrait
changer la donne
il ya tout un travail de terrain à faire
pour que les membres qu'on a recruté
vote et il ya un processus le ici c'est
pas un python sur internet là il faut
remplir un papier il faut se
photographier son permis de conduire à
temps il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
pris une carte qui t'a bien excité bon
les candidats la vie qui vont pas voter
dans une course à la direction il ya
toujours presque la moitié qui n'a votre
porte les hôtesses sont étonnés parce
qu'ils étaient pourtant ces dix mois des
militants sont motivés ils veulent
gagner non le processus l'airbus oublie
en plein été et ça va tourner un nouveau
procès d'autres choses alors est ce
qu'on est capable du côté des
différentes machines d'aller faire
sortir le vote pas encore plus important
dans une élection parce que le processus
est complexe ça ça devrait être
surveillé dans les proches moi bravo et
merci pour le détour à washington que je
sais faire
merci au revoir michel et à l'est qu'à
la prochaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit